how much are you willing to
sacrifice to
suffer I have given up
everything not
everything my
Lord we have located
new ring send the
NZ all of
them I know what you fear
tning the ring can enslave the minds of
men we must hold to our purpose no
matter what the
cost I will not let them be slaughtered
like my brothers at the black
gate we we need to build our
army this is just a
beginning Saron will not stop until all
the Middle Earth is
dominated we do not serve the dark
lord we will take this land for our
own you fight for
moror you fight for the bright
Lord what new devilry is this I come
from
you try not to kill him too
quickly new
ring our
ring is not m with his
shadow it is
perfect I strke down men corrupted by
these rings do not become one of them
when the time comes I will do what is
needed submit to your
destiny right to your
master and give him this
message I come for him
[Music]
yeah